calendars that I suppose that you have
already been in contact with the ditches
Peace Prize laureates what you haven't
so you don't know their reaction we felt
that if we called Malala in advance the
news would become known immediately so
we did we made no effort to get in touch
with her we tried to get in touch with
South yachty but it didn't work out so
we have not actually spoken with either
of the laureates you don't know what the
reactions will be there will be
contacted by by international
journalists of course we will get in
touch with them as soon as we can some
sometime later today do you think that
this year's decision by the Nobel
Committee will be characterized as a non
controversial decision well in a
Scandinavian comtex this will of course
be a non-controversial but there is a
big world out there and child labour
exists in many different forms in many
different countries we are moving in the
right direction I mean the number of
child laborers is going down fortunately
but I think in India and Pakistan for
instance i think the official response
will be positive I mean they will be
pleased that they finally have a Nobel
laureate but there will be many economic
interest in these two countries and in
many other countries in Asia and Africa
in particular where this will be seen as
a troublesome price oh well you
characterize your personally this year's
prize well it puts together certain
dimensions which have been there in our
history but have not been presented
together as they have been this year I
mean we this is a human rights price
sake I humanitarian price yes exactly
it's a combination of a human rights
price and a humanitarian price with very
clear political undertones I mean India
and Pakistan hindu-muslim so there are
many dimensions none of
entirely new except that their
combination may be felt as as a fresh a
new one you have been close to the
committee as the director of the Nobel
Institute and a secretary you're so the
secretary of the Nobel Committee how
difficult do you think that this yes
process has been it is always difficult
because there is a tremendous sense of
responsibility I mean when the Chairman
steps up to the microphone and announces
this name we have we must have done our
homework I mean we must have worked this
through in many different ways we had
278 candidates which is the highest
number we have ever had the committee
took its time we had seven meetings but
we always take the time available no
decision should be made until at the
final meeting we did reach a decision
fairly late but we're happy with the
outcome the nobel peace prize is by far
the world's most prestigious and the
most important piece price among the
year well somebody say about 300 peace
prizes in the world what kind of impact
do you think that this yes decision will
have on that may image for the prices I
mean there are many who seem to think
that the nobel peace prize is some sort
of magic wand I mean you wave it and
whatever problem we have tried to
address will be solved of course this is
impossible I mean five unknown
Norwegians cannot really change history
in any dramatic way we are normally
talking about long processes and doing
away with child labor is a very long
historical process the world has
actually made very substantial progress
I mean the number of people in child
labour has gone down dramatically in the
last couple of decades we hope that this
price can speed up this process somewhat
i forgot to the price
to Malala what kind of signal do you
think that this decision by the
committee will send to the Muslim world
well we hope that the signal will be the
emphasis on education education for girl
I mean that is her primary cause that is
what she has been talking about all the
time and we think this is an important
part of the wider message with it which
is preempted by presented by satya but I
think she has become a very forceful
spokesperson for girls education and if
she can speak again if she can speed up
this process and I'm sure she will I
mean this is a tremendous achievement in
itself the first nobel peace prize was
aborted in nineteen hundred and one and
since that there's been many successful
prices and the committee has been
criticized several times what is the
most successful price during these more
than 100 years and which price you'd
never have been awarded at all I mean
the first part is easy and I think to
kind of overstate the argument just a
little bit that our most successful
prices have been our most controversial
prices the price to a confidence yet ski
who was the symbol of resistance against
Hitler very controversial the King
didn't come to the award ceremony two
members left the committee huge debate
in Norway all over Europe the awards to
sakharov and terrico lenze very
unpopular in the Kremlin and of course
Dalai Lama and Leo shabo quite unpopular
in Beijing so yeah there's nothing wrong
with controversy as long as the price
addresses the most important principles
for the committee this does not mean
that all controversial prices are
successful but I think this is this is
our honor roll in a certain sense some
people say that the gay
Nobel Peace Prize to a young woman like
Malala would be like hanging a milestone
around her young neck what do you think
well we waited we did not give Malala
the Nobel Peace Prize last year the
committee took its time we have seen her
in action throughout the world and in
the committee has been remarkably
impressed by how she has been able
despite her young age to speak up and
have a tremendous impact I mean it's we
see it all the time people are moved
they are incredibly mood by Malala so we
took our time but we are very optimistic
that this will work out well but of
course it's true I mean she said she say
she's a girl she's 17 years old and this
will dramatically change her life and we
hope for the better and this must be a
great ceremony on December the 10th yes
we should have a ceremony with a lot of
color with a different kinds of music
and bringing together various cultures
so I think it will be a big event yes
thank you mr. learn to stop thank you